happy friday my happy friday friends
and happy july 4th weekend right huh
from your favorite little firecracker me
just remember to be careful out there
i'd hate to see you lose a finger
like my childhood friend we had to call
mittens
so in case you scoff at the idea that
the media works from the same script the
same playbook the same oxygen deprived
brain you need to see thursday's la
times piece on how late nights alleged
comedians covered the january 6 hearings
all the late night shows the times
covered featured the exact same unison
response or should i say unisom
since they were dull enough to put a
meth head into a coma we we are coming
to you just hours after the january 6
committee shocked the world with a
hearing that can only be described as
i too were shocked to hear that trump
threw any of his food away
because i mean let's be honest this
guy's taking more selfies with food than
he has with some of his kids right
immediately the agents were like who the
hell let him out of his car seat
now knowing trump uh he probably
finished his big mac first then through
the plate isn't that unreal who has
ketchup at lunch wow well those shows
should come with a warning do not
operate heavy machinery
afterward
or expect amusement while viewing they
aren't even trying to think outside the
box maybe because it's now a coffin
where comedy goes to die
it's like they all think comedy isn't
their job and if you watch a few minutes
you'll agree it's not even their hobby
instead
instead their job is to spout acceptable
liberal elitist assumptions to be safe
meanwhile their audience feels like
they're in a tv room at gitmo and pete
exit has been holding the remote
which explains why their audience is
shrinking like it's got a speedo full of
ice cubes
meanwhile our ratings are sick and sick
sick in a good way
yeah
i think that's what the teens say
we're sick
in a good way not in a hey what are
these stores and why do i want to eat
bananas and fling my feces
shout out to monkey pox
but we aren't just stealing their
viewers we're taking the ones with the
big fat wallets it's like we're doing a
smash and grab on them and taking only
the good stuff which leads me back to
the la times they covered what the late
nighters said about jan6 but
mysteriously left off one show now what
show could that be
do you think it's the one that a isn't
parroting the other shows
b and is beating the crap out of him in
less than a year of being on air
and c whose host is hotter than the
handle of a cast iron skeleton skillet
not even letting me finish
i want to reread that one
and c
whose host is hotter than the handle of
a cast iron skillet
left in the oven for three hours
[Applause]
thanks for riding that cat
yes that's this show the gutfeld show
so why would the la times leave us out
of their recap what could their
reasoning be
well there is none when the leading late
night show is bucking the conformity of
those other shows you'd think that would
be a story perhaps even a big one for
the writer whose beat is late night tv
but no they ignored this show like it
was me trying to get a lap dance at
applebee's
i get confused
it's all those bright lights
again the question's why well it's like
the january 6 hearings if you don't show
the other side of anything it helps you
think it doesn't exist
it's like when your car is making a
strange noise so you turn up the radio
and suddenly the noise is gone
it's like covering your eyes and
sticking your fingers in your ears and
singing la la la la la
which is how doctors say is the safest
way to get through fox and friends
they don't watch
with few exceptions the mainstream press
has been over backwards to ignore our
success since ignoring it means we don't
exist there could be no viable
alternative to their crud fests true if
their mind if their minds were any more
closed they'd be a post office on july
4th
so what does that say about their
beliefs or their egos that maybe they
know that neither can stand up to a
challenge it's the same thing that
happened when fox news launched 25 years
ago they laughed they mocked and you saw
how that turned out we're stomping them
like grapes under the feet of an italian
winemaker
i get asked this question a lot from
college kids
where am i and why am i tied up
but also
how do i respond to people who outnumber
me on campus and trash me for my beliefs
you know i always say stab them in the
face
[Music]
with truth
and a knife
made of honesty
when people give you for being different
just say do you ever wonder why i'd
choose the harder path why would i make
it hard on myself i mean i could just do
you
so aren't you curious as to why i would
make myself less popular than a class
called intro to chlamydia
it's a question i posed to my
evaporating competition do you ever
wonder why we aren't doing you is it
because we're dumb or crazy
or maybe i know something you don't the
answer isn't as important as them
hearing that question it's like when i
asked my wife why your tennis pro is
living with us
sure i could do their liberal late night
stick pandering is the easiest form of
comedy i wish someone could explain that
to the writers at snl they're still
doing trump as an evil cheeto jokes that
were stale in 2016
while saying nothing about a president
who flopped off a stopped bike like he
was rounding a turn in the tour de
france
true people in this industry don't like
us meaning myself cat and tyrus
well i'm getting i'm guessing tyrus
catches a little less than the rest of
us
there's something about giving crap to a
guy who's not only smarter than you but
could fold you into his wallet
but i lost friends the more successful
this show became before i was just
harmless they could pat me on the head
and say he just doesn't know any better
but then when the winning began suddenly
they don't want you around anymore
they'll marginalize your ideas say that
you used to be funny but not anymore
they don't want to face you maybe
because i knew better than they did and
they don't want to have to fight for
their beliefs we must all agree or the
cocktail party sucks
what a chicken way to go through life
especially in this industry the la times
ignored us because they're cowards which
is lamer than the late night hosts they
drool over
in the future will they come around to
seeing why we're killing it
who cares we don't need him but hey our
door is always open unlike their minds
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guest
she's the only fox host to post nude on
a book cover besides stuart varney
hosted kennedy on fox business kennedy
he was the second best host of red eye
fox's contributor tom saloon
[Music]
take the state of new jersey add
hilarity and mix it with a bowl of
gravel
and you get actor comedian jim
florentine
[Applause]
and finally both she and california
expect a lot of blackouts this summer
[ __ ] news contributor cat tip
we have
dare i say a panel full of comedians
very funny people who probably have very
valuable insights on this topic
including perhaps you tom yes greg how
are you it's great i love this a block
we got the sh the uh rundown of the show
in email today and it said a block let's
talk about how awesome greg is
you know my producers should be a little
more subtle
it's not about me it's about all the
opportunities i give to everyone else
it is true and you you're killing it in
the ratings including the younger
demographic you have the youngest
demographic in late night which is odd
because
in the teleprompter you have the biggest
most elderly person font
it's true
[Applause]
i can't see anything
i probably won't be seeing you anymore
yeah
one question to you i want to move on to
kennedy because she's funnier um
do you think it's the comedians who are
concerned about being liberal or is it
the people like the producers and their
bosses it's all of them all together
they the thing is i used to think it was
a liberal bias but it really is a bias
toward the establishment
and those in power which is weird
because it didn't used to be that way i
worked on the daily show with jon
stewart when he took over the show in
1999
he came in and he said to everyone we're
going after the powerful who's ever in
power we're going after and he did that
for a while and his show was killing it
uh now you're killing it because you're
doing it yeah there you go very good i
am killing it yes
yes no need to applaud we're eating into
my valuable talking time every time you
applaud
kennedy
you
were this big star on mtv how many
people did you how many friends did you
lose like did you notice a sea change in
the people around you when you started
working at fox it wasn't when i started
working here it was in 2016. so when
trump was elected
that was the line in the sand so for
people who
in the past had been tolerant of my
views which you know had been
libertarian and conservative
that was fine for a while you know like
you said as long as you were the cute
little pet
but but once someone came into power who
offended the establishment that was the
line and a lot of people weren't willing
to cross it in order to be friends
anymore and it's a miserable feeling but
you know i look at the people
like chelsea handler and stephen colbert
who are formerly funny people who have a
great deal of personal experience and
and how they're so unfunny now and i
realized that fear is the worst way to
operate in comedy and i always think
like what would andy kaufman have done
would he have ever been afraid of
offending someone or losing friends
absolutely not like the joke was the
more important thing making people
uncomfortable and i'm really happy
there's someone making someone
uncomfortable because
the places like l.a times would love to
have an establishment
leftist column forever but it's boring
and it's failing and it's not where most
of the country is right now yeah well
you know there we go you know
i'd like to think that i make everybody
uncomfortable
i think i do i mean when you're gassy
yeah i'm gassy and i'm strange and i i
like to stare at people you know jim you
still have you i don't know what your
politics really are i can't figure them
out i but i assume that you still have i
don't think you're a liberal but you
have liberal friends so i can't even
tell do you find that comedians actually
give a damn about this stuff or some of
them do yeah you got to really be
careful with the conversation we try not
to even just bring it up yeah you know
you got the you got the people i just
want to play by the hollywood playbook
the comics what did judd apatow tweet
about this or let me put a tweet that's
similar
so if john ever is casting for a movie
maybe he'll see my twitter feed oh i'm
going to put him in because he thinks
like me
it's the hollywood playbook and then you
got the other guys say hey man just
brought it up there and tell jokes
what's the big deal right so it's a fine
line you gotta um ride but also with
these late night guys it's like
it's almost like the cover jokes like
all the comics have them and they're not
a hacky no one wants to hear them
anymore in a club they're waiting for a
new wave
over to come so they could bring back
those jokes and that's how these guys
are the late night guys trump's back oh
good he's he's in the news again we got
tons of material yeah same hacky jokes
like you said since 2016. yeah yeah they
come it is like it's a rotation like you
know like that little cake
display at the diner just keeps coming
around
i just like doing this with my finger
are you hypnotized
they like they hate when trump lays low
for like three weeks there's no
statements and then all of a sudden yes
he's back we've got jokes exactly we got
our kova jokes yes they need it kat why
are they so intimidated by us
he said us
because you always send me those
articles about the show
and i'm like why i'm not in this
i just searching for my own name i'm
never in there so what you're doing is
sending me an article about how great
you are again yeah
thanks you've lost friends you lost
course you lost close friends and it's
this when you killed them
no i'm non-violent it's the same thing
as as uh uh kennedy went through where
it's i've had my beliefs haven't changed
since i met some of these people i've
always been libertarian it's been
exactly the same but then it just became
not okay
that you know i've never voted for a
republican i've also never voted for a
democrat but then in 2016 and 2020 it
was not okay that i wasn't voting for a
democrat and then i
all of the history that i had with some
of these people over a decade some of
these people didn't matter because i was
now a horrible person and it like it
wasn't just an angry conversation i
actually don't have some of these people
that i was very close with in my life
even though i didn't change at all those
people changed and um the guy that i was
supposed to vote for
i think
things aren't going great
which guy yeah exactly yes
does it have to be a guy
and what for what depends on what you're
talking about yeah you're right women
political office
well you know the andy kaufman thing it
may be true we don't know greg this all
could be an act you could turn out to be
some left-wing communist and this whole
thing is a ruse hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else